you know when people think about climate
change a wildlife they probably think
about polar bears and maybe the Great
Barrier Reef well we can add koalas to
them now as many as 3 percent of the
country's New South Wales agent may have
a virus continue to ravage and destroy
their habitat the realities that these
flies are not normal
we're in a war zone so I know that
there's there's been you know loss of
human life definitely loss of property
here but what impact is this fire had
for this fire season had on wildlife in
Australia well over 1 billion animals
are thought to have died or will soon
die and the week's the months ahead
because of the current fires that's 1
billion and we've never had at all like
that on that wildlife but it seems that
every few days the statistics get worse
I don't know where we'll end by the end
of this fire season are there specific
species that are particularly being eyed
by this many many animals cannot flee
these big fires either they can't fly
they can't move quickly to cut power
they burn to death particularly because
Australia has bulldozed half of our
forests it's hard for wildlife to flee
somewhere else and that's why you find a
lot of animals including koalas are
wandering into people's backyards into
the streets looking for some habitat to
survive in when they panic they climb up
a tree that works when the fires low
down but it's almost a death sentence
when the fire consumes its crown fire
the canopy fire people have talked about
flames up to 200 feet in the air here at
70 metres I mean that is our trees
generally don't grow that big so any
wildlife that birds it or lizards that
go to the top of the trees to escape a
normal fire they're sitting ducks really
so I've seen a lot of particularly hard
to watch videos of koalas you know
basically charred from the fire like are
they are they gonna go extinct after
this how what's the status of the koala
now and what's gonna happen to them now
estimation is that koala numbers over
the last two hundred thirty years of
fallen by about 95% and these fires will
be eating out up towards ninety eight
ninety nine percent over time it's
important to remember that this bushfire
and the climate crisis is it has come
after a couple hundred years of
decimating koalas and the habitat so for
100 years
koalas were shot for their pelts and
there's records of eight million koala
helps being sold in the United States
the UK and I think Europe up till 1930s
when there was a moratorium put on
shooting koalas the term functionally
extinct has been thrown around in the
media during these fires in reference to
the koalas what is that what is
functionally extinct mean and is that
true the two functional extinction is
used for animals where they're only tens
or hundreds not even thousands of
animals wet so rhinos or animals where
there's 10 or 20 left we're not there
yet for koalas in eastern Australia
koalas a list of this earth a threatened
species but at the lowest level they're
called vulnerable we think they're now
eligible to be up listed to being an
endangered species there are solutions
to these problems koalas and polar bears
don't need to go extinct and the term
functional extinction doesn't help that
for people like me at home like watching
this heart-wrenching footage is there
anything we can do to help the situation
I think the first thing people can do
around the world is to read up about
what's happening in Australia be course
in protecting in our country if it's not
already happening in your country it
will be in the future of some type as
the climate gets worse and worse we need
to convince people don't care about
nature or the climate that particularly
decision makers governments presidents
prime ministers you have a role in
helping keep these species alive
[Music]